and we are here playing the character
have we done in our lives I mean I like
the Halloween pumpkin how would your BFF
describe you cunning delightful generous
intelligent definitely not and say I
want them to pick a celebrity to be a
running mate are you kidding me
obviously I'm choosing you bounce deal
how dare you as a choice and expect me
to choose anybody that's fair Paulsen
because she's about us and we'd win know
I'm supposed to do one she was a
fictional politician Oh Tracy Flick
that's a good that's nice I see that
that scans president in history Tracy
Flick all the way I'm gonna go with
Leslie Knope
the favorite school subject choose a
song to sing a karaoke commune rap
Sabine
what's that since you've been gone I
want to dance with somebody defying
gravity umbrella oh this is tough you're
gonna lead with the Beyonce's single
ladies and also throw me a defying
gravity and finish up with and I want to
do somebody oh boy a little Kelly Clark
sup in that biz Carson that's a good
idea I think I think I'm also gonna do
Kelly Clarkson because it feels a little
okay listen I feel like defying gravity
I wanna dance with somebody are very
difficult choices because
I guess if singing and singing and not
dancing to fine-ground Oh
I'm choosing scream queens hands down is
special ever and what are you choosing
oh my god another reason I chose Glee
Anna what oh I got what she just like
loves the little things like baloney
cups like dusty Oh someone who will do
anything to fit in mean even if it means
putting yourself and those around you in
difficult situations that is not true
BuzzFeed I got McAfee your friends often
turn to you when they need advice they
don't but let's go ladies and gents oh
god you're ambitious driven and a
natural-born leader
nothing will get in the way of you
achieving your dreams doesn't that make
you want to hang out with me fun watch
the politician on Netflix
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]